nein kommt rein freunde ist ist ein
großartiger tag für uns
wir befinden uns gerade hier in unserem
aktuellen beruf anderthalb jahre sind
wir jetzt hier drin aber es hat zeit für
etwas neues und genau das will ich euch
heute zeigen eigentlich sind wir super
happy wir konnten das büro genau nach
unserem geschmack anpassen und so
einrichten dass es super funktional ist
minimalistisch anpassungsfähig einfach
und günstig genug platz für viele leute
also so mäßig dazu komme ich aber gleich
nochmal überall hängt irgendwo was an
der wand nicht integration sondern weil
es wirklich sinn machen wir haben es
wirklich funktional eingerichtet alles
ist vernünftig schallisoliert und
irgendwie sind die kleinen dinge die uns
hier so gut gefallen und ist für uns
einfach so besonders von unserem wasser
passen genau zwei kästen nebeneinander
in diese kleine lücke unsere stühle
hängen an der wand nehmen also wenig
platz weg meine kidman komplett an der
wand und ich kann darauf immer einfach
zugreifen aber das büro ist vor allem
eins einfach zu klein ich sitze beim
drehen immer direkt neben den cuttern
stören die also beim arbeiten und sie
sind auflegen wie am tippen während ich
am aufnehmen und freunde was geht ab
welt willkommen zurück
in einer von uns telefonieren muss muss
er aus dem büro raus wenn es am regnen
ist unangenehm und auch so will man
einfach vielleicht an seinem platz
sitzen bleiben während man telefoniert
max hat keine richtige möglichkeit hier
zufrieden weil einfach kein platz für
eine vernünftige küche ist und ich habe
kein streaming was natürlich der einzige
grund ist warum so unregelmäßige streams
kammer
also haben uns dazu entschieden ein
neues
und was uns ziemlich schnell klar wurde
es ist quasi unmöglich auf dem freien
markt irgendwas zu finden und dazu ist
es unglaublich teuer und vielleicht
kennt ihr das auch ihr habt euch für
eine zu teure wohnung entschieden zu
teure einrichtung gekauft oder habt aus
irgendeinem grund zum beispiel etwas auf
raten gekauft annie für ihn unterstützt
aber nicht nur mich bei diesem video
sondern auch euch genau diesem problem
das ganze passiert so häufig dass laut
einer studie jeder zehnte deutsche seine
schulden nicht mehr bezahlen also
vermutlich auch ein paar leute verläuft
und genau für diese leute ist endlich
ein gedacht also nur leute die bereits
verschuldet sind die lösung des problems
ist aber eigentlich ganz einfach
funktioniert so ihr ladet euch die andy
winter und ladet dort die letzte
kreditkartenabrechnung oder letzten
abrechnung hoch und andy film prüft ob
sie ein günstigeres angebot wird haben
wenn das der fall ist und wirklich nur
wenn sie ihnen angebot haben das
günstiger ist unterbreiten sie euch
dieses angebot auch um ihr könnt dann
entscheiden ob es an nehmen wollt oder
nicht das ganze ist komplett kostenlos
und absolut unverbindlich
falls ihr das angebot annimmt hier der
alte kredit abbezahlt und ihr zahlt mit
eurem eigenen raten plan den er in der
app selber einrichten können weniger
oder können sogar atempause einlegt mit
dem coach dave bekommt ihr 20 euro
rabatt also klickt auf den ersten blick
in einer video beschreibung schaut euch
das an wenn ihr verschuldet seit und ich
danke vielmals dass sie mich auf dieses
projekt unterstützen jetzt geht es
weiter mit dem wir haben also gesucht
gesucht gesucht und nachdem wie die
hoffnung quasi schon aufgegeben hatten
wieder mal nur durch kontakte etwas
gefunden das ist hier einfach nicht
anders möglich und was wir gefunden
haben dass sie die jetzt und damit
herzlich willkommen in unserem neuen
büro vielleicht seht ihr es schon im
hintergrund ist unglaublich es ist ein
diesen großen euro wechseln von 50 auf
180 quadratmeter also mehr als
verdreifacht es halt hier ewig nach
es ist eine richtige halle also wir
starten erst mal direkt hier vorne es
gilt halt jetzt für uns zu planen was
kommt wohin wir richten wir das einen um
den platz möglichst offen zu haben mit
diesem fall geht es aber natürlich nicht
also hier müssen definitiv wänden
reingezogen werden max braucht eine
küche eine riesengroße küche damit er
endlich im büro auch vernünftig drehen
kann und die wird genau dorthin kommen
das ist schon fest aber das im prinzip
das einzige was fest ist die toilette
hier direkt neben dem bad ist auch quasi
fest weil die wollen wir nicht verrücken
die städte einfach und da bauen wir
quasi drumrum ansonsten ist das hier das
büro da wo leo mit der kamera gerade
steht ist der eingangsbereich da ist die
große tür wir haben hier über die
komplette breite große fenster und auch
noch mal in den decken ihr seht schon
ist riesengroß diesem bereich würden wir
uns ganz gerne offen behalten einfach
zum drehen und weil es geil ist auf den
bereich zu haben in dem man stehen kann
brainstorm kann und einfach so ein
studio weib nicht verliert weil das ist
hier im prinzip quasi ein atelier rechts
auf der seite küche das ist klar und die
toilette
hier offener bereich und dann gibt es
noch einige dinge die wir unterbringen
müssen mittlerweile haben wir so viel
equipment dass wir einen richtigen
equipment raum brauchen der muss in
irgendeiner weise sicher sein vor
einbrechern und so weiter direkt
dahinter mit dem streaming raum kommen
und direkt an den anderen beiden stellen
oder direkt neben dem streaming raum
müssten eigentlich alle büros kommen
damit wir vernünftig abgetrennt sind es
ist riesengroß und haben eine menge
möglichkeiten jetzt heißt es planen
gedanken machen und es wirklich in 3d
alles so umsetzen wie wir es haben
wollen vermutlich die größte
herausforderung ist es das büro so
einzurichten dass wir alle negativ
punkte die ich kann eben genannt habe
eliminieren können und gleichzeitig
irgendwie den flair aus diesem büro hier
behalten also ein funktionales kleines
schickes einfaches bewogen also kleine
ist gut aber es soll halt nicht so sein
dass man sich los darin fühlt und dass
wir ungenutzte fläche haben sondern wir
wollen das von vorne bis hinten perfekt
in nutzung haben und dann natürlich noch
jemanden finden der es mit uns gemeinsam
ausbaut weil es müssen wände gezogen
werden dann einrichten und diesem
prozess will ich auf dem kanal jetzt so
ein bisschen begleiten weil ich mich
immer mehr so ein bisschen für
demokratie interessiert es reicht
natürlich noch nicht dass ich mir eine
wohnung kaufen jetzt haben wir ein
mietobjekt und das könnte so ein erstes
projekt sein in dem ich probiere mich da
ein bisschen rein zu arbeiten und das
einfach so nice zu machen wie wir es
alle gerne haben wollte und das will ich
über ein paar videos sie begleiten wir
haben dann klar verschiedene
raumaufteilung ausprobiert das ganze
soll so sein dass wir keine durchgangs
räume haben also dass wir bei niemandem
durch büro müssen um in einen anderen
raum zu kommen zweiter wichtiger punkt
war dass die cutter und max und ich
getrennte räume voneinander haben und
damit alle eben vernünftig arbeiten
können dann hätte ich gerne in streaming
raum wie gesagt max küche in großer
offener studiobereich und einfach eine
lagerfläche weil wir mittlerweile so
viel krieg redmond licht stative und so
weiter haben dass es irgendwo verstaut
sein muss weil es sonst im normalen
arbeitsalltag einfach stört wenn das mit
einem raum rumsteht und nach version 1
und 2 die alle sie ihre kleinen tücken
hatten und wir das immer wieder in der
gruppe besprochen haben was daran anders
sein muss habe ich diese version version
3 gefunden auf der rechten seite haben
wir das büro quasi in drei abschnitte
unterteilt büro 1 für die katz 24 max
und mich und ganz hinten lagerraum und
ein kleiner streaming raum den ich dann
auch hauptsächlich benutzen werden man
kommt in allen büros rein ohne durch
andere wollen wir durchlaufen zu müssen
man kann den lagerraum benutzt während
irgendjemand am stream ist man kann aber
auch natürlich durch den lagerraum gehen
während dort gerade jemand kameras
zusammen geschraubt um in den streaming
raum zu gelangen in der mitte haben den
riesigen studio bereich also irgendwie
so ich glaube 70 quadratmeter oder so
also ein unglaublich riesiger raum dort
kommt ein essbereich ein wohnbereich und
ein studienbereich hin alle sachen sind
aber natürlich so gestaltet dass man in
allen szenen drehen kann max braucht den
esstisch häufig beim essen ausprobieren
ich brauche im sofa
weil ich bestimmt auch mal auf dem sofa
drehen will und dann der gewohnte
studiobereich team hinter mir sät der
wird quasi auch mitgenommen in das neue
studien dazu auf der gegenüberliegenden
seite können immer noch große stative
große licht stative und so einfach aus
dem weg geräumt werden und man hat immer
noch genug platz um durchzukommen zum
einen zur toilette und anderen zu max
großer show küche die wird natürlich so
eingerichtet dass max ebendort perfekt
drehen kann gleichzeitig kommt aber auch
eine traverse an die decke und alles
wird es drei kabeln ausgelegt dazu haben
wir kabelkanäle und am boden liegen so
dass wir aus jedem raum streamen können
aus der küche aus dem studienbereich aus
dem essbereich vielleicht sogar aus
unseren büros quasi überall sollen
kameras oder die möglichkeit für kameras
seien also die raumaufteilung steht das
ist alles ziemlich perfekt aber jetzt
heißt es in den nächsten videos richtige
einrichtungen finden das ganze
feintuning das büro wirklich
einzurichten einzuräumen natürlich die
wende zu ziehen die küche aufzubauen es
gibt unendlich viel zu tun und ich
möchte das gerne hier so ein bisschen
auf dem kanal bleibt ganz einfach weil
so viel neben mein haupt videos passiert
natürlich will ich gerne die ganze zeit
geben wir uns ausland fliegen und dann
nur riesige videos machen aber es
passiert so viel nebenbei rahmen den zu
organisieren gilt dass sich das auch so
ein bisschen auf dem kanal mit begleiten
möchte und das büro einzurichten ist so
ein spaßiger teil noch von dem
organigramm das ich mich freue dass
einfach in videos zu verfassen ich hoffe
euch hat das video gefallen wenn ihr an
lass mir gerne leider vergessen ich den
kanal zu abonnieren und dann sehen wir
uns am sonntag zu einem haupt video
wieder oder in den nächsten wochen zuvor
in richtung